eat your food i'm practicing
practicing for what the prince
oh yes stop he's a liar and a coward and he killed
my friend you better give me that sod you want it
i'll give it to you i already killed one fat boy
i bet you never killed anyone anyone can be killed
fetch that water jack and her a girl
gives a man his own name that's right
you're good you're not as
good as you think you are
face tits balls i hit him right
where i wanted to do the [__]
where did you get the knife from you
next time you're going to do something like
that tell me first that's a fine little
blade maybe i'll pick my teeth with it find a
little blade maybe i'll pick my teeth with it
what's your name rouge thank you
you're learning
[Music]
you're the first person on my list you know
for killing cereal pharrell remember him
probably not i'm arya stark [Music]
do you know who you are you're no one
you're nothing who are you no one ow [__] lie
sad little lie who are you i told you i'm gonna
do that again who are you you're about to find out
[Music]
and now he's been promised another name [Music]
that won't help you
[Music]
finally a girl is no one a girl is arya stark
of winterfell and i'm going home [Music]
they weren't easy to carve
my name is arya stark i want you to know that
the last thing you're ever going to see
is a stark smiling down at you as you die
leave one wolf alive and the sheep are never safe
tell them winter came for house
frey so for the last time [__] off
i'm getting into this castle one way or another
[Music]
who taught you how to do that
i know death
he's got many faces
i look forward to seeing this one
my weapon i'll get right on it [Music]
wow
[Music]
good
you